did Jennifer Lopez just call Drake her  booty call he used to call me on my cell  phone  here's the deal the 47 year old singer  has seemingly been using a snippet of a  song that sounds a lot like rumored ex  Drake's hotline bling at her Vegas show  for months now here's a clip from back  in February while Lopez never confirmed  her romance with Drake it's worth noting  the 31 year old rapper did mention her  in his song free smoke which dropped in  March I dropped his JLo oh no soy  bounce-back boy I wonder got to bounce  back  of course Lopez is now dating Alex  Rodriguez she recently gushed about her  main man to ET I'm really proud are you  happy in your relationship right now I'm  very happy thank you  you